today on the matt walsh show joe biden
declares that global warming is the
greatest
threat we face but didn't he just say
that white supremacy is the greatest
threat which is democrats keep cycling
through different boogeymen and fear
tactics we'll discuss that also
five headlines including the
rehabilitation of jeffrey toobin
featuring perhaps the most
cringe-inducing video of all time
no not video of not that video of him
doing that but a different video
and a young girl speaks up against
gender theory in school we have that
video play plus
i heart media puts out a job listing and
declares that it wants quote
diverse applicants only read not white
isn't that completely illegal finally in
our daily cancellation we have the
harrowing tale of korean canadian sitcom
stars
who spent five seasons on a show and now
that it's over they say that they're
being
victimized by racism the whole time hate
it when that happens that and much more
today on the matt walsh
whether he personally realizes it or not
joe biden is right now on a trip to
europe
mostly so far he's bumbled and stumbled
around speaking half intelligibly
allowing his wife to do much of the work
for him so not much different from his
normal routine but
one part of his remarks to a group of
u.s air force personnel in england
has caught some attention he claimed
that
global warming is the greatest threat to
the u.s and more disturbingly he said
that the joint chiefs
told him so listen to that we must all
commit to an ambitious
climate action if we're going to prevent
the worst impacts of climate change
limiting
global warming warming to no more than
1.5
degrees celsius lead the global the
global transition to clean energy
technology
you know when i went over in the tank in
the pentagon when i first
was elected vice president with
president obama
the military sat us down to let us know
what the greatest threats facing america
were the greatest physical threats
this is not a joke you know what the
joint chiefs told us the greatest threat
facing america was
global warming because they'll be
significant population movements
fights over land millions of people
leaving places because they're literally
sinking below the sea in indonesia
because of the fights over what is
ariable land anymore
global warming our greatest threat
countries are sinking
under the ocean the ice caps are melting
people are fighting with one another
because they're so annoyed by how
humid it is i guess we need our military
to help fight climate change
maybe they can invent some sort of laser
to destroy the sun and cool things down
a bit
because ultimately of course the sun is
what determines the weather
and the temperature here on earth you
know that the giant
900 000 mile diameter scorching ball of
gas burning at 10 000 degrees and which
could fit a million earths inside it
yeah that's the real culprit driving
climate change not your suv
you egomaniac i'm not sure what the
military plans to do about it um if it's
not the destroying the sun i don't know
what it is but it's interesting to hear
joe biden
call this the greatest threat we face it
was only a week or two ago
that he made a very different assessment
he had a very different take
on our greatest threat as i said in my
address the joint session of congress
according to the intelligence community
terrorism from white supremacy is the
most
lethal threat to the homeland today not
isis not al qaeda white
supremacists that applause again
just love that applause white
supremacists are going to kill us all
amen
uh white supremacists so which is it are
we are we all going to drown
or or are we going to be killed by
roving gangs of nazi klansmen
i need to know joe what's it gonna be
maybe it'll be both
maybe we'll be drowning and then the
nazi klansmen will come up in their nazi
kayaks and finish the job i don't know
this could be a tag team situation
between global warming and white
supremacy or perhaps
white supremacy is causing climate
change
that's how you thread the needle and if
you think that white supremacy causes
climate change it's too stupid
even for the modern day left you haven't
been paying attention
here is um johnny on the spot here an
article on
the sierraclub.org titled racism is
killing the planet
and it reads in part during the street
protests in marches many people carried
signs that read racism is killing us
it's no exaggeration to say that racism
always premises harm all of us
actually that is an exaggeration but
anyway because in addition to robbing us
of our humanity racism is also
killing the planet we all share an idea
long overdue
realization is growing in in the
environmental movement
it goes something like this we'll never
stop climate change without ending white
supremacy
this argument has entered the outdoor
recreation and conservation space space
thanks to the leadership of black
indigenous
and other people of color in the climate
justice movement the pollution-spewing
global mega-corporations that created
cancer alley
are just the latest evolution of the
extractive white settler mindset
that cleared the forests and plowed the
prairies and just as the settlers had to
believe and tell stories to dehumanize
the people they killed
plundered and terrorized today's systems
of extraction can only work
by dehumanizing people okay well that
clears things up
it's the extractive white settler
mindset that causes all the problems
come to think of it i did hear the
meteorologist on our local news
here a few days ago mentioned that he
said that there was a heat wave coming
apparently because a high pressure
system
had moved up from the gulf and had
combined with an extractive white
satellite mindset
and now we can expect 90 degree
temperatures through the weekend
science is fascinating what's also
fascinating is to see
democrats sort of cycle through
one fear tactic one man-made panic after
another
there's of course nothing new or
especially interesting about politicians
using fear to manipulate generally
speaking they've always done that
democrats certainly are not the only
ones doing it now
but what makes this unique is just how
many panics they try to cause just how
unsafe they try to convince us we are
especially in comparison with how safe
and secure we actually are
i mean in the past politicians might
pick one crisis
one boogeyman and try to ring that for
all it's worth
but democrats these days aren't
satisfied with one
they tell us that climate change is
destroying the planet sinking cities
under the sea
we have less than 10 years to live they
tell us that a white supremacist army is
prowling about plotting and scheming
ready to strike at any time
they tell us that a rowdy group of
trespassers in the capital were actually
militant insurrectionists
who came close to overthrowing the us
government by taking selfies at nancy
pelosi's desk
they tell us that racism is an epidemic
it's killing thousands in this country
every year they tell us that racist cops
are
literally hunting black people in the
street and murdering them for nothing
every day
they tell us about a whole array of hate
crime epidemics especially hate crimes
targeting trans people
and we haven't even mentioned the
fear-mongering that caused millions of
people to spend a year locked in their
homes
with muzzles over their faces all of
this
all at once and i've only provided a
partial list
so much fear
all the time such a dark and dreary
vision
of the world that we get from the
democrats meanwhile back here in reality
life still contains its normal dangers
and you know we are still sure to die
eventually of something
that's true but for most of us
day-to-day existence
is safer than it's ever been we are more
physically secure than we've ever been
provided you survived the womb of course
which is still a very dangerous place
thanks to planned parenthood
and not counting the physical risks to
children that they might be drugged and
mutilated if they experience a little
bit of
gender confusion gender confusion that
was implanted in their minds
so there are threats out there serious
ones some of them
physical many of them psychological and
spiritual
but these democrat politicians they
don't talk about any of that in fact
they are largely responsible for much of
that
instead they want you to fear the things
that pose
little danger to you they want you
constantly running
from imaginary monsters
and then the idea is you won't notice
the real threats
when they come now let's get to our five
headlines
well fortunately we are getting a
reprieve from some of the gift-giving
holidays for a while but there's a lot
of other occasions you might have coming
up for
for for gifts birthday anniversary
wedding gift whatever it is and if
you're looking for the perfect gift um
paint your life is it this is a
guaranteed hit
paint your life uh with painting your
life you get a professional hand-painted
portrait created from any photo at a
truly affordable price
you can choose from a team of
world-class artists and work with them
until every detail is perfect
we've been through this process twice
now and that should tell you how we feel
about it
it's a quick and easy process you get a
hand-painted portrait in about three
weeks i personally was shocked by how
quickly
you know originally i thought well maybe
this will take a couple months or
something but no
just a few weeks and again it just makes
the perfect gift
for someone else or for yourself um and
we we we are greedy so we've gotten our
paint life
paintings for ourselves in our own homes
at paintyourlife.com
there's no risk if you don't love the
final painting all your money is
refunded guaranteed and right now
as a limited time offer get 20 off your
painting that's right 20
off and free shipping to get a special
offer text the word matt to 64 000
that's matt
to 64 000 text matt to 64 000 paint your
life
celebrate the moments that matter most
terms apply available at paint your life
dot com slash terms again text matt to
64 000.
speaking of uh threats endangering us
all you know the cicadas
we hear so much about and it's been kind
of a dud here in tennessee for the most
part i haven't seen
very many cicadas and i was thinking
about this last night
uh has anyone come up with a good
cicada related conspiracy theory yet
because if do i do i need to work on
that or someone else done it
and i'm not saying what it should be but
it seems like someone by now would have
something
maybe uh you know because cicadas aren't
real they're it's a hologram
it's a distraction technique maybe
cicadas are
uh tiny little government drones spying
on us
we can work on it but i really think
someone we don't have long here and uh
we've got this
once every 17-year event
and no one's come up with a conspiracy
theory for yet we got to get on that
someone's got to do it
all right so this is really what we have
to start with i'm afraid and
it's not appropriate for children or for
anyone
frankly but jeffrey tubin cnn
legal analyst obviously as you know
uh showed his tube during a zoom call
with colleagues a few months ago
in fact you know he was he didn't just
show it he was uh
he was you know handling the situation
so to speak
right there in front of everybody on the
zoom call and uh it really kind of
rubbed everyone the wrong way as you
might imagine and he was fired for or
not fired
it you you'd think that you would be
fired for that
masturbating you know workplace
masturbation
the kind of thing that you would think
would get you fired especially in the
metoo era
well that's not what happened because
he's back now he was back on cnn
yesterday
and they for some reason decided to
on tv have a conversation
about tubin's masturbatory habits
and they brought a woman in allison
camerata to have this discussion
this is i think the most cringe inducing
thing
to ever air on cable news
i mean it's oh i actually have not seen
this entire video yet
because i can't get past 15 seconds it
is so
it the cringe is overwhelming it's
nuclear grade
cringe this is a cringe comet
um an absolute volcano an explosion of
cringe well
i'm going to stop on that i'm not going
to go any further with that analogy
anyway let's uh
let's try we're just going to try to
watch this and see how far
we can make it let's go ahead here in
october
you were on a zoom call with your
colleagues from the new yorker magazine
everyone took a break for several
minutes during which time
you were caught masturbating on camera
okay stop can you stop
i can't i can't go any further
why are they doing this and why is he
sitting there i'm asking why
rhetorically i know all the answers to
my question but so
why is he sitting there enduring this
embarrassment
i know he wants his job back and
everything but he's been how old's this
guy
he's probably in his 60s now he's been
on tv a long time doesn't have money
saved up
how could you ever how are you showing
your face again
imagine this guy walking through the
hallways of cnn
he ends up in a break room grabbing a
coffee with someone that was on that
zoom call
like hey uh how you been
why would you want to endure that
there's no amount of money
that could make that worth it go off
into the into the woods
grow your beard out you know you you can
have all
you just you can do everything you're
out of sight do everything go ahead and
do what you need to do out there
and live out the rest of your days
all right let's we're going to keep
going we're going to try to make it
through this
you were subsequently fired from that
job after 27 years of working there
and you since then have been on leave
from cnn
do i have all that right um you got it
all right sad to say
okay so let's start there um to quote
jay leno
what the hell were you thinking well
obviously
i wasn't thinking very well or very much
and
um it was something that was
inexplicable to me i think one point
i wouldn't exactly say in my defense
because nothing is really in my defense
i didn't think i was on the call i
didn't think other people could
see me you thought that you had turned
off your camera
correct i thought that i had turned off
the zoom call now that's not a
difference
wait stop it there first of all
inexplicable
his own masturbation was inexplicable to
him
what is what does that even mean
he's looking down at himself going
what's going on right now
and then he says uh he didn't know that
his co-workers could see him
so what he's saying is yeah i was i was
masturbating in front of my co-workers i
didn't but i didn't know they could see
me
and that makes it okay
all right how long is this video let's
just
let's just let's just make it through go
ahead this was
deeply moronic and indefensible
but i mean that that is part of that
that is part
of the story um and you know i have
spent this seven
subsequent months miserable months in my
life i can certainly
confess um trying to be a better person
i'm miserable therapy
i think i think people had to see that
jeffrey working in a food bank which i
certainly am going to continue to do
working on a new book about the oklahoma
city bombing but i
am trying to become the kind of person
that people can trust again working in a
food bank i don't want this guy handling
my food
but people that are going to a food bank
they've had they're having a hard enough
time and now they've got a chronic
public masturbator
serving their food
oh man the whole thing is
is uh i don't even know what to say
probably i've said too much
as it is but let's can we be clear about
about one thing
okay as cnn tries to oh well a couple
things to be clear about
cnn's trying to re rehabilitate this guy
because he's one of their own
right um this they would never do this
right if this wasn't someone that they
had a personal attachment to they would
never do this
almost anybody else their life is over
for this
certainly you you lose your job for that
like this is take
me too out of it take cancel culture out
of it
in any normal scenario
you take your pants off and do that in
front of co-workers
you're gonna lose your job and you're
not gonna get it back
it doesn't matter what era we're living
in it doesn't matter anything you're
going to lose your job for that
but cnn's going to rehabilitate why is
louis c.k
is still persona non grata he's he's
still in exile from
polite society how do you justify that
if jeffrey tuban's allowed to come at
least louisiana got consent first before
he did that
jeffrey tuban didn't ask anybody
but also another thing to be clear about
is yes
and somehow this has been lost in the
whole conversation
he didn't know his camera was on i i
believe that he didn't know the camera
was on i think that much is clear but he
was on a zoom call
in a work meeting and he knew that
so he is doing that his plan
was to do that while watching
this meeting right he was he was trying
to
do that during a meeting
that part was intentional the
unintentional part was that the camera
was on
so i go back to how is that not a a
permanently fireable offense
all right let's let's get away from this
we got to move on somehow
somehow someway pick up the pieces and
move on
all right a little bit of a pallet
cleanser here here's another
uh we'll go to ron desantis here's
another episode of ron desantis
being right about something he was
interviewed a few days ago by the daily
caller
and um uh i really liked what he had to
say here i think we have the video clip
what advice would you give to american
voters on how to tell the difference
between a politician who's going to use
their vote or who's actually going to
fight the culture wars
well here's the thing on right to life
when i became governor i
inherited the most liberal supreme court
in the united states
it was a four to three split by the time
i became governor
but i was able to replace three of the
liberals to make it a six to one court
and that's important because
florida had the worst abortion
jurisdiction
jurisprudence in the in the country way
worse than even things like
planned parenthood versus casey you
couldn't even do parental notice they
would strike down almost anything
even with minors it was it was crazy so
we've changed that
now we've been able to advance pro-life
legislation now some of this stuff is
going to be
going to be tested in our state courts
but i think those precedents are
going to be re-evaluated and so we have
an opportunity to do even more um in the
years to head and so
you know i think it's something that is
a fundamental issue uh
and i think here's what i tell people in
terms of right to life it's important
obviously on its own
but the people that that aren't
supportive of the life cause
they're not people you want to be in a
foxhole with on any other political
battle as well they're the first ones
that will sell out to the dc
establishment when the going gets really
really tough
and he's got the black cowboy boots also
with the with the uh with the suit which
is a bold choice and i
and i like that not really the point the
point is what he said there which
is exactly correct this is another
example another episode of ron desantis
saying something that's true
also the kind of thing that every
republican should be saying though a few
of them do because they just don't have
um the uh they they either don't believe
it
or they don't have the guts to say it
and that's this is exactly right
and i myself have been preaching this
forever as you know that the the life
issue
is one of the central battles
battlefields in the overall culture war
um
and you need you need that you need to
engage in that fight you can't surrender
on that issue because if you surrender
on that issue then you're surrendering
on you're surrendering on the whole idea
of
life having inherent value or you give
up on that and you say whatever happens
with abortion it's not important
not only are you consigning 60 million
more babies to to death and counting
but you're giving up on the idea that
life has inherent value and if life
doesn't have inherent value then i don't
know what
sort of where you go from there what
other what other thing can you argue
about and what do you base your
arguments
in if not a belief in the inherent
dignity and value of human life
you can't go on to you can't start
talking about your
your rights on any other issue you can't
say
yeah i don't know if human life has any
inherent
value or dignity uh but our our second
amendment rights those are really
important why are they important
if your life has no value then who cares
if you can protect your life or preserve
it
and what are what are your
this right you're speaking of where does
it come from
that's exactly right um
as far as the issue itself and also it
is a good
litmus test and pro-lifers have always
known this
it's not that we think that abortion is
the only important issue it's one of the
most important
but we also know that it's a litmus test
and we know that if we can't trust
someone on that issue we can't trust
them to fight it
and to be consistent then you can't
trust them on anything else
right another encouraging video we could
play for you this is from fox it says a
14 year old in virginia is speaking out
about what she says is a sexist move by
the loudoun county public schools to
allow boys into girls locker rooms the
policy followed a previous
um a previous one that committed the the
county to providing an equitable safe
and inclusive working environment
regardless of sexual orientation
or gender identity and other individual
characteristics
the more recent proposed policy states
in a draft
that students should be allowed to use
the facility that corresponds to their
gender identity
now we've seen a lot we see a lot of
videos from school board meetings
especially
loudoun county where they've they've
really been fighting this out
but i wanted to show you this this is
jolene grover
who got up and spoke and she's wearing a
shirt that reads woman is female
so she is answering my infamous question
what is a woman she has an answer for
and i like her answer
i also like everything else she has to
say here let's listen
two years ago i was told policy 1040 was
just an umbrella philosophy
and you weren't going to allow boys into
the girls locker rooms but here you are
doing just that
everyone knows what a boy is even you
your proposed policies are dangerous and
rooted in sexism
when woke kids asked me if i was a
lesbian or a trans boy because i cut my
hair
short it should tell you these modern
identities are superficial
my guidance counselor's response to my
concerns about bathroom privacy and
safety was
well there are stalls in the bathrooms
now boys are reading erotica in the
classrooms next to girls
and you want to give them access to
girls locker rooms and you want to force
girls to call those boys she you do this
in the name of inclusivity while
ignoring the girls who will pay the
price
your policies choose boys wants over
girls needs
and we'll look past the fact that she's
being forced to wear a face mask there
for no reason
but here is what do we say 14 year old
girl
an 8th grader and she's teaching these
adults
about basic biological science
now we need children to stand up and
tell adults and speak
common sense to adults educate them
what's the i go back to again
why send your kid into an environment
where they're going to have to teach
the teachers you're not even sending
your kids into school to be taught
anymore
they have to be the ones doing the
educating now
the teachers are the ones in school they
have to have to learn about these things
and so here's just one now we don't
often hear
and this will be something that's often
pointed out by the left
that you know we don't often hear a lot
of
young girls standing up in front of
microphones
and speaking out against this kind of
thing and actually saying i don't want
boys in the locker room with me
we don't hear it that often why don't we
hear it
is it because they they're all okay with
it is it because none of them
value their privacy
no it's because they're kids and most
kid
forget about kids most people most
adults don't have the courage to do
what jolene grover did just there
especially
kids don't have it and the difference
between kids and adults as far as echoes
is kids have an excuse
because they're just kids and they
shouldn't be put in this situation to
begin with
i mean kids should not be in a situation
where they have to stand up and
actually explain why they don't want
boys in the girls locker room
so i don't blame the kids who remain
silent in that situation
but most do because they're afraid
obviously i mean this this whole idea
that
well the kids aren't complaining most of
them anyway and the ones who do
they're bigots mostly kids aren't
complaining so sure they must be fine
with it
obviously this is a view held by
any rational person
and the kids who don't feel that way
it's because they've been berated
into believing that they're not supposed
to feel that way
think about the situation a lot of these
young girls are in they're made to feel
guilty for wanting privacy if they if
they want
basic privacy and security the basic
privacy security
that we all had in school and growing up
and it was never an issue we never had
never had to even think about it
right if you were a girl growing up and
going to school in the 90s
you went into your locker room there was
no notion that any guys would be in
there and if they did
they'd be tossed out and suspended
so that was something you had that was
something we all had didn't have to
think about
and now it's an issue and i think there
are a lot of kids also that are being
they're they're being psychologically
beaten down
and indoctrinated and they have this
obviously natural
desire for privacy and security like
anybody else would but now they're made
to believe that that is it's somehow
bigoted and they have to resist that
within themselves
that it's their fault the problem is on
them
that's what they're telling girls so
we're saying to like
13 year old girls in a locker room if
this boy comes in
and you don't like it you're the problem
you are the problem there is something
wrong with
you not him or her quote unquote
all right this is from
cns news it says an executive producer
at america's largest owner of radio
stations iheart media
advertised a job thursday by stating we
are looking at only diverse
hires at this time only diverse hires
quote unquote molly socha executive
producer of custom podcasts
at iheartmedia made the statement in an
email sent to a listserv
interested in the new york city radio
industry and obtained by cns news
socha said quote diversity is incredibly
important to our team and our company so
we're looking at only diverse hires at
this time
while the iheart media media producer
made this stipulation in our email
apparently is nowhere to be found in the
public listing for the job
instead the public announcement states
that i heart media
is an equal opportunity employer and
will not tolerate discrimination in
employment on the basis of race color
age sex sexual orientation gender
identity expression
religion disability ethnicity national
origin marital status protected veteran
status genetic information or
any other legally protected
classification or status
which is of course exactly what they're
doing this is a violation of
equal opportunity employment they're
saying
uh that because we can translate this of
course when they say we're only looking
for
diverse hires in other words we don't
want a white person
and so in order to ensure diversity
they're eliminating
ahead of time an entire category of
people they are
they're they're limiting the number
of people or the pool that they're going
to select from in the name of diversity
narrowing it down in the name of
diversity
and the whole idea that a a person
can be diverse i i don't know exactly
what that's supposed to mean
you've got a diverse person versus an
undiverse person or a non-diverse person
here's an update to this story though
posted last night
socha emailed the nyc radio list served
shortly after being contacted by cns
news with the following statement
i made an error in language in my last
note so i just want to clarify
all are welcome to apply and we will
consider all qualified candidates
that being said in our efforts to
elevate diverse voices in the
predominantly white podcast space
we strongly encourage engineers editors
of color regardless of gender and sexual
orientation
to apply yeah that's a little too late
for that
you made an error in language no you
didn't you expressed
what you're looking for that's not an
error in language it's not an error at
all
it's actually not a mistake you were
being very clear about what you wanted
it should be too late for that i mean
there should be a lawsuit against
a massive lawsuit against iheart media
for this
just like there would be if they sent
out an email saying
you know we're really looking for a
white employee on this one
that's really what we're looking for
you think they could send out that email
and then the next day or a few hours
later say oh
no no no we yeah we'll we'll consider
non-white employees also or non-white
applicants
no they've they've revealed their intent
and that should be enough right there
all right one other story i wanted to
mention
very quickly this is from the daily mail
it says kim jong-un
calls k-pop a vicious cancer and
threatens anyone caught listening to it
with 15 years in a labor camp
i didn't read the entire story that's
all i just i just read the headline
k-pop obviously it's korean pop music
like boy bands and stuff
he says they're a vicious cancer and all
i'm gonna say is broken clock and all
that
uh i gotta agree with him on this one
i'm on his side on this one
15 years in labor camp
might be a little lenient though let's
go now to read the youtube comments this
is from
taishan paxton says the thought of matt
walsh twerking makes me laugh
like camila when she's asked a question
she doesn't want to answer laugh
why would me expressing myself through
the medium of dance make you laugh
you're banned from the show joppa says
how is it possible that matt has less
than half a million subs come on folks
the guy deserves a million subscribers
yeah i agree
where do you all get off not subscribing
to me what are you trying to prove
exactly
what's your deal if you want to be in
the sweet baby gang
you need to subscribe you're not in the
gang
um luke says the first rule of sweet
baby gang is we don't talk about sweet
baby gang well then why are you talking
about it
luke and um
gibberish the username gibberish says
matt start in
only fans and twerk for money then give
the money to a boiler
you know there are limits to my
philanthropy and you've i think you've
probably identified them
actually i've gotten so many requests
over the last week with people asking me
to start a gofundme for this or that
i should just announce right here that i
am i am stepping back from my
philanthropy for a while i'm kind of
retiring from
philanthropy in order to focus on
amassing wealth just for myself
so that's what my focus is going to be
on it's going to be for a while
mark says i like listening to matt but i
generally disagree with hi
with most of his takes on officer
encounters
everyone knows it's easy to be a monday
night quarterback without thinking about
things in the moment
i think monday morning is usually when
people do the quarterbacking
while i will not say it was right or
wrong for the officer to use the pit
maneuver on that vehicle
i will say that he did pay attention to
his surroundings
he's referring to who played the video
yesterday there was a pregnant woman
this was in arkansas she was driving
along on the highway at night she was
going 84 to 70.
officer tried to pull her over she
thought she didn't have room in the in
the shoulder so she moved over to the
right lane
she put her hazards on she slowed down
she was looking for an exit she went for
about two minutes
looking for an exit and the officer
decides to pull a pit maneuver
hitting the vehicle and she flipping it
this is a pregnant woman
on the highway because she didn't pull
over
to a reduced shoulder within two minutes
he just flipped the vehicle on the
highway mark says that he's uh he's
basically okay with that it sounds like
anyway i'll continue with mark
he says the only vehicle to have been
damaged was the suspects
the suspect she was going 40 miles over
the limit
suspect the only uh
uh in hindsight it's easy to make a
judgment that this was just a civilian
who was caught speeding but for the
officer there was a chance that it could
have been something more
had it turned into something more and
the officer didn't stop the vehicle
before
it got into more congested traffic than
this would have been a different story
the woman had ample opportunity to pull
over on the side as the traffic appeared
to be low
but she chose to keep going for an
officer all you have is a split second
to make decisions that can go horribly
wrong or positively right
which is why there's a saying that the
sugar can turn to
crap real fast is that a saying i
actually haven't heard that saying but i
like it
um yeah mark i i think you're just
completely i don't buy that at all
first of all i'm not sure why you say
you don't agree with my take on officer
encounters most of the time
most of the time on the show we're
talking about an officer encounter with
one of these high-profile incidents i'm
defending the officer so it seems like
you probably would agree with me most of
the time
on this one i don't defend the officer i
think the officer obviously should be
fired
and probably there should be criminal
charges as well
because this is negligent at a minimum
to flip someone's car because they
didn't pull over
within two minutes when they signaled
that they were complying and they were
looking for a safe exit
and you should remember mark i i read
for you a document
um from the arkansas department of
public safety
and they tell you what what do you do if
you're on the highway and you're getting
pulled over
put on your emergency flashers and look
for a safe spot she did exactly that
she followed the protocol and he flipped
the car because it wasn't fast enough
come on no way is that no way
is that defensible i i defend police
officers
all of the time or most of the time
because most of the time when there's a
high profile police encounter that's on
video and then
and then it's out there on social media
and there are protests and everything
notably there are no protests over this
by the way that could have anything to
do with the fact that
the woman was white could it but in most
of those cases
the officer is being unfairly maligned
and so i'll defend them
that doesn't mean you defend the officer
reflexively every single time no matter
what
yeah you can't use the oh he only had a
split second
thing here he didn't have a split second
this was this was a very
low stakes normal sort of thing he's
pulling someone over
they're just going 14 miles over the
limit on an empty highway
we've all done that there's no reason to
assume
that there's something more going on
just based on that
um and
the the car was signaling that it was
compliant
and just because it wasn't fast enough
for his taste
doesn't mean that he could put our life
in jeopardy and flip her car
i thought that's something we could all
agree on but of course we can't all
agree on anything
these days you know it's no secret that
the amount of content from the daily
wire is growing rapidly both in numbers
and in quality from our new
investigative journalism to our sports
column
to my now incredibly altruistic and
generous podcast where i save abuelas
purely out of the kindness of my heart
and for attention
there's so much to see here in reid that
even the most avid daily wire member
might not be keeping up
you can now get all of that on the daily
wire app even if you're not a daily wire
subscriber you'll be the first to know
what's trending with mobile
notifications for the latest news and
all of your favorite content only a
touch away so download the daily wire
app and you can stay up to speed with
the freshest conservative voices around
no matter where you are
and speaking of staying up to speed if
you're looking for a permanent cure for
what medical professionals are calling
whiteness
you're not going to find it in my weekly
newsletter in fact you'll probably
find an abundance of the opposite if
we're going off the fantasies of
what that ailment is supposedly is
you'll also find some tips fun facts
updates and potential
comments about twerking as a defense
mechanism i mean there are many things
in it it's really just a rambling stream
of conscious
i don't know if this is selling it very
well but still you want to sign up for
my for my newsletter
so head to dailywire.com matt walsh
report
we just started this newsletter now and
already we got a lot of people signing
up for it so again that's dailywire.com
matt walsh report and subscribe to my
newsletter right now
right now now let's get to our daily
[Music]
cancellation
today we begin with the stunning
revelation that they have
tvs in canada apparently they even have
their own tv stations and tv shows that
to me was the biggest news
to come out of a recent report from the
la times about controversy surrounding
the show kim's convenience evidently
kim's convenience is a canadian sitcom
featuring
a number of uh korean canadians and the
show has now ended after five seasons
which brings to mind the old proverbial
question
if a show airs on canadian tv for five
seasons did it ever really air at all
we'll leave that to the side and get to
the article because as it turns out many
of the actors on the show have decided
now after five seasons
that the whole thing was terribly racist
reading from the la times it says
kim's convenience has officially closed
up shop and its stars are opening up
about their frustrations with the show's
approach to korean canadian
representation behind it in front of the
camera after the hit cbc sitcom debuted
its fifth
fifth and final season last week on
netflix actor samuel liu and jin yoon
voiced their concerns regarding the
series overwhelmingly white production
team
horse poop pay and overtly racist story
lines
among other alleged grievances oh i see
after the show had finished filming and
the checks were about to dry up
that's when the actors bravely stood up
65 episodes and five years later
to denounce the overt racism
see they've already made it so that if
their claims are
of racism are true then they are
self-serving cowards who cooperated with
it and went along with it for the sake
of cashing checks
best case scenario for them is that they
are merely spineless selfish gutless
money grubbers or they could just be
full of crap
i'll let you be the judge actually i'll
be the judge but you could be the judge
too
so what sort of racism could there have
been this was a show about korean people
featuring a cast of mostly koreans
what complaints could they have we'll
keep reading
it says that semulu one of the actors
who now has a deal to star on a netflix
marvel series
quote expressed disappointment with the
way that he and his character were
created
as the series um were treated rather as
the series progressed
he said quote i was however growing
increasingly frustrated with the way my
character was being portrayed and
somewhat related
was also increasingly frustrated with
the way i was being treated
he then complains that a non-asian
actress on the show will be getting her
own spin-off
remember this dude is going going into
marvel okay he's making marvel money
but he's resentful that a white woman
might be having a little moderate
success of her own
he says quote of that woman i love and
am proud of nicole and
i want the show to succeed for her but i
remain resentful of all the
circumstances that led to the one
non-asian character
getting her own show and not that they
would ever ask but i will adamantly
refuse to reprise my role in any
capacity
i mean he reprised it five times for
five seasons
but now he adamantly refuses
right after he got the the marvel deal
now he
i am putting my foot down
i am going into marvel i'm not going to
do this canadian sitcom anymore
on principle but yes he loves uh his
friend nicole and is proud of her
it's just just that he's also resentful
of her career success
if this is how he treats people he loves
and is proud of i hate to see what he
does
to people he hates and from there lou
and other actors on the show complained
that they were grossly underpaid
and unappreciated and everyone was mean
to them and it made their tummies hurt
also they say there was a lack of
diversity now given that this was a show
of mostly asians
when they say lack of diversity do they
mean that there was a lack of diversity
in the sense that there should have been
more
non-asians no of course not
they say now that there were too many
whities in the writers room
quote the scene partners also addressed
the alleged absence of diversity on the
kim's convenience writing team which
quote
lacked both east asian and female
representation as well as a pipeline
to introduce diverse talents according
to lou
aside from inns he's the guy who made
the play that the show is based on
there were no other korean voices in the
room
and personally i do not think he did
enough to be a champion for those voices
including ours
when he left without so much as a
goodbye note to the cast he left no
protege no padawan learner no
korean talent that could have replaced
him as an asian canadian woman
a korean canadian woman with more
experience and knowledge of the world of
my characters the lack of asian female
especially korean writers in the writers
room
of kim's made my life very difficult and
the experience of working on the show
painful according to yoon
very difficult you see painful there are
people out there struggling with cancer
hunger disease despair of all kinds but
her life was
very difficult because the hit sitcom
she starred on didn't have enough korean
women in the writer's room
this is something to think about the
next time you're tempted to believe that
your own life is hard
you know maybe you lose your job maybe
you lose your marriage maybe you
maybe your house burns down well before
you complain
think about gene yoon the underpaid
sitcom actress
with too many white people in her
writer's room i mean that ought to put
your own trials and tribulations and
proper perspective
so what can we learn from this well
nothing really i mean we should already
be aware of the lessons here the first
is that our current environment of
full-on racial hysteria
has made it incredibly easy for one
grifting con artist after another to
line up and take advantage
it's been it's been declared that a
person of color quote unquote
cannot possibly be wrong if they claim
that they're victims of racism
it doesn't matter how privileged they
are doesn't matter how powerful they are
it could be a literal billionaire like
oprah doesn't matter
if they say they're a victim of racism
or a victim of any kind
we must not risk invalidating their life
their lived experiences by asking any
questions
let alone denying their claims outright
the other lesson is once again
and most importantly it's never enough
nothing is ever enough the racial
grifters cannot ever be satisfied
because the whole grift
is to not be satisfied you know the
irony of batman is that he needs the
joker well the
sjw types they need racism that's their
super villain they need it
to justify their whole world view
and just as the joker is a fictional
character the vast majority of the time
the racism that they're fighting against
is also fiction and that's how you end
up with an entire show about korean
people
starring korean people and yet still
somehow it is racist against korean
people
and it lacks representation of korean
people
that was always inevitable the end
result is baked into the cake from the
start
there will never be a time when they say
okay you know what
we've actually done a pretty good job
addressing the racism thing it's not a
huge problem in society anymore
and we could probably move on to other
issues that will never happen
it can never happen because the claim of
racial victimhood is where the race
hustlers
derive their power and that's why you
might as well stop trying to appease or
satisfy
or cooperate you'll always be called a
racist
those who would accuse you of racism
will still accuse you no matter what you
do
all you could do is throw up your hands
and say whatever i don't care anymore
i'm not playing this game and also you
can say
of course you're canceled and we'll
leave it there for the day and the week
thanks for watching everyone thanks for
listening have a great day talk to you
on monday godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 hey everybody
this is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started so come
on over to the andrew clavin show and
laugh your way through the fall of the
republic with me
andrew clavin